en temps normal en plein coeur de
journée au mois de mai c'est sur les
bancs d'école que ces jeunes sont assis
ils vivent ici une toute nouvelle
expérience simple lecteur des fois
jouent tous dans le dos puis
physiquement sinon ça devient une fois
en apprennent et avec ses amis
je me suis en étant à sa robe c'est
calme on peut se mettre la musique mais
le lendemain matin en irak et qu'est ce
qui les motive à travailler dans les
champs
ils sont payés au salaire minimum et
grâce à une mesure mise en place par
québec ils reçoivent 100 dollars
supplémentaires par semaine s'ils font
un minimum de 25 heures de travail la
ferme laviolette est très heureuse de
pouvoir compter sur ses jeunes car cette
année il manque de travailleurs
étrangers temporaires au lieu de 22
mexicain elle n'a que 15 actuellement
dans les champs et le rythme qui vont
prendre le voyais pas mal plus rapide
que nos jeunes qui viennent de commencer
et l'auteur sont sont habitués à
travailler rapidement puis à apprendre
vivre puis bon c'est go go go go go bain
pour pour équivaloir à ce qu'une équipe
de habituels ou être capable de faire
comme lendemain ça me prend plus ça me
prend plus de plus de travail en part du
l équivalent donc plus de salaire
les pertes financières sont inévitables
si officiel mais bon ça fait partie de
la situation actuelle on va vivre avec
la plante est entré beaucoup d'énergie
en ce moment avec elle est comme toute
sortie en même temps puis les nuits sont
chaudes aussi fait que ça pousse très
très très vite
d'infos et faut être assez rapide pour
réussir à récolter tout ce qu'est ce qui
te qu'est-ce qu'ils vont la journée mais
parce que le lendemain déjà si on n'a
pas réussi à combler à faire tout le
chien il s'est dit mais c'est donc
heureuse d'avoir toute l'aide possible
elle leur laisse tout de même du temps
pour faire leurs travaux scolaires mais
ce travail dans le champ contribue aussi
à leur éducation
d'une certaine façon ici marilyn marceau
radio-canada saint-étienne-des-grès